I think that it's really impossible to
do something unless you you really care
about something and I think that's a way
for science and for academics and for
friends and I think most importantly
they just needs to be some kind of
functional connection that once you hit
something you know it just kind of
clicks and that you need to aggressively
pursue that a lot so I was very
fortuitous that my first experience was
science with stem cells and that was
just a very natural fit and I think that
the first real at really really big step
is just finding something you believe in
and then after that you can definitely
make things happen